[Music]
what's up Wolfgang we can now say that
Avengers infinity war is less than two
weeks away and although I do love the
Avengers very dearly
I am ready to see Thanos kick their
butts for two and a half hours yes all
the hype about this movie seems to be
about Thanos and how strong he is and
how he's just gonna come in and murder
everybody the Russo brothers have stated
that they are making him out to be the
biggest baddest villain that the MCU has
ever seen they've also stated that
Thanos will be the main character and
that Infinity Ward will be told through
Thanos his perspective
Thanos has been described as the
ultimate personification of sad ISM
cruelty megalomania infinite destruction
death power and madness but at the heart
of them behind his quest to eliminate
half of the people in the universe is
there good in him is he actually the
good guy today we'll be talking about
why Thanos wants to balance the universe
but first if you hit that subscribe
button good things will happen you can
trust me so there may be no way to make
you trust me but we need to go I think
we've all seen the trailer by now of
Gamora saying that Thanos wants to wipe
out half the universe in the same
trailer we also hear Stano say when I'm
done half of humanity will still exist
now if you think about what Gamora says
you think he's crazy right he's this mad
Titan running around who wants to kill
half of the beans in the universe but if
you really dissect what Thanos is saying
it actually has a different meaning than
I want to kill half of the people
because he's not saying when I'm done I
will have killed half of humanity no
he's saying when I'm done half of
humanity will still exist in order to
really understand this you have to know
why Thanos is out to eliminate half of
the universe or balance it there are
different storylines in the comics but
I'll talk about what I think will be
most relevant to the MCU and Avengers
infinity war the main reason Danis is
out to eliminate half of the universe is
to save it that's right the mad Titan is
actually trying to save the universe
when he was younger his home planet
Titan was experienced in a cataclysmic
shift they were going out of resources
and they were overpopulated this is what
Danis made the recommendation that they
exterminate half of the population in
order to save the rest of the population
of course Thanos his idea was rejected
and he was branded a madman hence the
name Thanos the mad Titan Titan would
ultimately get destroyed and Thanos felt
that if they would have just listened to
him they could have saved their race
from here on out Thanos took it upon
himself to save the universe
he went planet to planet and killed half
of the population on each one balancing
the universe and Dan owes his own eyes
he's a savior not a villain
he is rebalancing the universe to save
it he considers himself a hero he's out
to save the universe from extinction due
to overpopulation so if we go back and
look at what Danna said in the trailer
he says when I'm done half of humanity
will still exist it means something
different now in his eyes killing half
of humanity will save the other half of
humanity instead of letting all of
humanity die this is why I think we see
some empathetic moments from Thanos in
the trailers for example in one trailer
he is talking to who we believe to be
Iron Man and he says I hope they
remember you Thanos is being genuine
here and he's showing a lot of empathy
towards Tony Stark why because in a
really ironic way they're kind of the
same person Tony is trying to save his
planet just like Dan knows tried to save
his home planet Titan and although
Thanos may feel for Tony he ultimately
believes that he is saving the universe
and will stop at nothing to rebalance it
I'm sure this may seem kind of touching
but let's not forget that last part he
will stop at nothing to kill half of the
universe and this will most likely
include some of our favorite Avengers
the second reason that Thanos could be
rebalancing the universe is because he
is madly and desperately in love with
mistress death death is sad and
complains that there are more people
alive than there are dead and Thanos
being desperately in love with her sets
out to rebalance the universe for her
it's kind of sweet if you can you know
look past the whole him killing half of
the universe there's a lot of theories
and speculation going around that hella
from thor ragnarok will actually play
the role of death it's believed that
Thanos ran into
Thor ship that contained the rest of
Asgard on it because he was on his way
to Asgard to find hella Thanos being in
love with death is a huge plot to the
comics so I really hope that this
storyline is in Avengers infinity war or
Avengers 4 so these are the two main
reasons that Thanos is out to rebalance
the universe I'm not sure which one
they'll go with or maybe they'll go with
both but what do you guys think and are
you a little more sympathetic towards
Thanos right now or do you still think
he's a big huge purple jerk that's gonna
kill all of our favorite characters let
me know what you guys think in the
comments below and also let me know if
you have theories of your own please be
sure to give this video a like and
please subscribe to my channel árbol and
all things super see all the passing you
so much for watching
look what did we win any it's a small
price to pay
[Applause]
right it
run from it the end is near we're gonna
need some help
have you been [ __ ] not bad for the end
of the world